you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news
on today's programme a crisis of fire
and ice
we look at how heat waves in the
northern hemisphere have led to
unprecedented blazes in siberia
how passive cooling instead of energy
intensive aircon
could help keep homes cool as global
warming
ticks up and meet the unexpected
sharp toothed climate superheroes
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions
yakatya is one of the biggest and
coldest regions in russia's siberia
but it's on fire unprecedented blazes
have ripped through more than one and a
half
million hectares of land releasing
choking smog and fumes
as the region experiences what officials
say is the driest
summer weather in 150 years it's not the
only place affected by extreme
temperatures and unusual weather
over recent weeks large parts of the
northern hemisphere
have experienced extreme heat and severe
weather events
a heat wave in russia last month led to
moscow recording its hottest ever
june day nearly 35 degrees
and a few days later the north american
heat wave meant a record high in canada
with litten in british columbia reaching
49.6
degrees celsius now the heat in the
northern hemisphere
led to forest fires breaking out in
siberia and the pacific northwest
of the united states and deep in the
siberian arctic
the temperatures led to unprecedented
ice melt in the laptop sea
it can be seen clearly in these
satellite images
here's the level of ice three years ago
and here's what it looks like this month
and the consequences of this
extreme heat have been picked up by
satellites tracking changes in the
atmosphere
smoke particles or biomass aerosols have
been circulating the northern hemisphere
this is the path of emissions from the
siberian and north american forest fires
plumbing high into the upper atmosphere
and merging to form a streak
covering 6 000 miles around the earth
and the record summer temperatures are
continuing in siberia
here you can see the heat this week with
temperatures well into the 20s
as wildfires continue to rip through
forests
our correspondent diana magnay has been
out with firefighters
near the city of yakutsk in the russian
arctic
russia's forests are burning one and a
half million hectares in the worst hit
region of yakutia
after another exceptionally hot and dry
summer
we're out with pavel petrov who's
coordinating the response around
yakutia's badly hit gorney district
[Music]
speeding along freshly dug trenches
which are meant to keep them at bay
[Music]
where there's smoke there's fire the
forest smoldering a little further along
the trenches
most wildfires start from a lightning
strike during a dry thunderstorm
but these fires are set by the
firefighters to clear through the dead
wood
and undergrowth so that when the real
big wildfire comes
it's got nothing to burn on it's
literally fighting fire
with fire andre piston who's been sent
in to help from the west of siberia
shows us
proudly what his men were dealing with
the day before
each fire needs its own individual
strategy and with
so many burning across siberia it's only
those the firefighters can even reach
that they tackle
that means that many burn unchecked
emitting
huge amounts of carbon into the
atmosphere as they do and they're
burning on permafrost
which as it thaws emits greenhouse
gasses too
it's been a long hard month for power
[Music]
patrol
siberians have always had to deal with
the most extreme temperatures on earth
now as these wildfires increase in
intensity
they are also bearing the brunt of our
changing climate
dynamagne sky news in gorny siberia
and you can read more about the extreme
heat in the northern hemisphere and the
wildfires in siberia just head to sky
news dot com
forward slash climate
and multiple wildfires are still burning
in parts of west coast of the united
states a huge
blaze from california has spread to the
state of nevada forcing
several communities to be told to leave
their homes
meanwhile the country's largest wildfire
is in oregon and it's now grown to more
than
618 square miles in size
that's just over half the size of the
state of rhode island
in today's other climate news a climate
calculator has been created to
let people decide which policies should
be used to reduce carbon emissions
the tool by think tank demos lets users
see how decisions such as
flying less and eating vegan would help
the uk meet its target to reduce
emissions
by 2030 it gives a breakdown of costs
and shows people the effect each policy
would have on their lifestyle
a two-day meeting of g20 environment
ministers is taking place in italy
president of cop 26 alok sharma is among
those attending and topics for
discussion will include how to increase
climate finance pledges and reduce
carbon emissions
the g20 is formed of 20 of the world's
richest economies
[Applause]
and communities in tanzania are using a
tree monitoring app to help restore
forests the charity called trillian
trees
is working with local people to plant
900 000
trees with the aim of creating
sustainable supplies of timber and fuel
while protecting biodiversity to make
sure these planting efforts are
successful
the app is used to register and to check
the health of the new
saplings parts of the uk have been
experiencing extreme heat this week and
according to the met office these
temperatures could become the norm by
2050.
while air conditioning may seem the
obvious answer it will only make global
warming worse in the long term
that's because ac units alone were
responsible for a
billion tons of co2 emissions in 2019
but passive cooling could be the answer
a cheaper and more climate friendly
solution
using low or no energy consumption
the chimney effect is one example it
uses cool air which enters from
lower ventilation like windows to absorb
the heat
this hot air then rises and escapes
through openings higher up
building materials such as brick or
stone have a high thermal mass meaning
they absorb heat and radiate it back out
but shading prevents this from happening
and homes in hot countries often use
white paint
on walls and roofs scientists recently
created the
whitest ever paint which they say
reflects 98
of sunlight as well as radiating
infrared heat into space
reducing the need for air conditioning
well let's bring in elizabeth
quarter colossal an architect in
barcelona who specializes in energy
efficiency in her designs
elizabeth a very warm welcome to you
what features specifically do you
include in your designs to help with
this passive cooling
so first of all is to know the condition
of
the place and to respond it with the
design tools and these design tools are
for example the the openings of the
building
um the quantity of insulation
you use the kind of materials
uh the the same design the volumetry of
the
of the building out um how it
responds to the to the natural elements
that you have in the place now many
homes in the uk for instance simply
weren't built for the heat
is there anything that can be done for
existing homes to retrofit them to help
with this
cooling if we are talking about
uh restoration of old buildings or
existing buildings
uh first of all is insulation of course
that is very important to
regulate the internal internal climb of
the
of the building the second one of course
it depends on the characteristic of the
building
you you have but one is the solar
protection that
you can apply on almost all the facades
and openings
and uh then um
cross ventilation that is very important
like cross natural ventilation that
but of course in this case uh it depends
on the
distribution that you you have not
always you can you can do this you can
apply this point
and what countries are best at building
these
homes that are that are designed to stay
cool who should we be looking to
as an example the example comes from the
traditional the good traditional
architecture
like for example the solar chimney we
use
it comes from the arab architecture
because
they of course during
during time they they had very very
warm summers and so they used these
this device to cool uh different
floors of the building using a black
solar chimney to take out the the warm
uh
air from from the inside for example
that's very interesting indeed
elizabetha colossa thank you very much
indeed for your expertise today thank
you
and finally they're hollywood's favorite
go-to villain
but sharks are actually climate
superheroes
they can teach us about how the seas are
changing and help maintain the natural
balance of our ocean's ecosystems
here's your 60-second guide to how jaws
helps the planet
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well that's everything from us for today
tomorrow it's 100 days to go until the
biggest climate summit in years cop26
and we'll be looking ahead to the
meeting why it matters
and what might be decided you can see
that here tomorrow on sky news
thanks for watching and we'll see you
[Music]
then
you